but I do want to say a quick thing about
nuclear energy where I you know this is
something that I really this so
precisely feels like Aerospace before
SpaceX where from everything that I know
about all of these I am the physics of
this stuff hasn't changed and the
reasons why things are expensive now are
not fundamental
I somebody should be going into a really
hard Elon Musk style at uh Vision
economical Vision not Fusion where the
fusion is the the kind of the the
darling of people that want to go and do
nuclear because it doesn't have the
taint that fission has in a lot of
people's minds but it's an almost
absurdly complex thing where nuclear
fusion is you look at the tokamax or any
of the things that people are building
and it's doing all of this
infrastructure just at the end of the
day to make something hot so that you
can then turn into energy through a
conventional power plant and all of that
work which we think we've got line of
sight on but even if it comes out then
you have to do all of that immensely
complex expensive stuff just to make
something hot where nuclear fission is
basically you put these two rocks
together and they get hot all by
themselves that is just that much
simpler it's just orders of magnitude
simpler and the actual rocks the refined
uranium is not very expensive it's a
couple percent of the the cost of
electricity that's why I made that point
where you could have something which was
five times less efficient than current
systems and if the rest of the plant was
a whole bunch cheaper you could still be
super super valuable so how much of the
pie do you think
could be solved by nuclear energy by
fission
so how how much could it become the
primary source of energy on Earth it
could be most of it like the reserves of
uranium as it stands now could not power
the whole Earth but I am you know you
get into breeder reactors and thorium
and things like that that you do for
conventional fission uh there is enough
for for everything now I mean solar
photovoltaic has been amazing you know
it's I I one of my current projects is
working on an off-grid system and it's
been fun just kind of again putting my
hands on all this stripping the wires
and wiring things together and doing all
of that and just having followed that a
little bit from the outside over the
last couple decades there's been
semiconductor like magical progress uh
in what's going on there so I'm all for
all of that but it doesn't solve
everything and nuclear really still does
seem like the smart money bet for what
you should be getting for base band on a
lot of things and solar may be cheaper
for uh you know peeking over air
conditioning loads during the the summer
or things that you can push around in
different ways but it's one of those
things that's it's just strange how
we've had the technology sitting there
but these non-technical reasons on the
social Optics of it has been this major
forcing function for something that you
know really should be at the the
Cornerstone of all of the world's
concerns with energy it's interesting
how the non-technical factors have
really dominated something that is so
fundamental to kind of the existence of
the human race as we know it today